Congress goes to work this morning with
no health care vote scheduled in the
house President Trump says the newest
Obamacare replacement bill will protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
and satisfy his supporters they're going
to give the greatest these are the
greatest people we're either gonna have
a great plan I'm not signing it vice
president Mike Pence is leading the
president's lobbying effort on Capitol
Hill but some Republicans are still
backing away from the bill Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill counting the
potential votes Nancy good morning good
morning and White House officials have
said publicly they want to see a vote
this week they think they've got the
votes but they must be looking at
different numbers than Republican
leaders here on Capitol Hill and frankly
CBS News because right now our
unofficial whip count shows that if they
were to hold the vote today it most
likely would fail Republican leaders can
only afford to lose 22 of their own
members and 20 have already confirmed to
CBS News that they are against the
current version of the health care bill
and there are many more who are still
undecided and Republican leaders are
losing some members who would normally
be loyal backers congressman Billy long
of Missouri surprised a lot of people he
comes from a lot of state that left from
a state rather that went for President
Trump by 19 points but he has changed
his vote from yes to no thanks to a new
amendment that allows states to strip
away protections for people with
pre-existing conditions in a statement
long said the mcarthur amendment would
make coverage for many people
unaffordable and he called that
pre-existing guarantee quote one of the
few good things about Obamacare after
announcing that he was switching his
vote that congressman's office confirmed
that he received a call from President
Trump himself Gale trying to get him to
change his mind all right Nancy thank
you very much